[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اخبار العالم بايجاز غرفه اخبار الجزيره
اهلا بكم بعد لقائه قاده الانقلاب في
النيجر وفد وساطه العلماء المسلمين
النيجيريين يؤكد الاتفاق على تكثيف الحوار
وينقل عنهم انفتاحهم على الدبلوماسيه لحل
الازمه وبرلمانو مجموعه دول غربي افريقيا
يقرر ارسال لجنه الى النيجر عقب خلافات
تسببت بتعذر انعقاد اجتماعي الاتحاد
الافريقي بشان النيجر مع توالي استهدافه
مسيرات اوكرانيه لمناطق روسيه الجيش
الاوكراني يضرب قاعده عسكريه للقوات
الروسيه في خرسون ويدمر مستودعي ذخيره في
المنطقه والبحريه الروسيه تعترض وتفتش
سفينه شحن في البحر الاسود في حين اكدت
كييف العمل على تفعيل الممرات البحريه
المعتمده في اتفاقيه نقل الحبوب موجه حر
شديده تضرب دولا عربيه عده ودرجات تتجاوز
معدلاتها الطبيعيه ففي سوريا زادت موجه
الحرب من معاناه النازحين في المخيمات في
حين حذرت السلطات في فلسطين من نشوب حرائق
في مناطق الاحراش بسبب ارتفاع درجات
الحراره اما المغرب فقد دعت المواطنين الى
تفادي التعرض للشمس مع وصول درجات الحراره
الى مستويات قياسيه وزاره الاتصالات
العراقيه تعلن رفع الحجب عن تطبيق
تيليجرام بعد حظره في السادس من اغسطس
الجاري لاسباب تتعلق بالامن القومي حيث
كشفت الوزاره ان الشركه المالكه للتطبيق
استجابت لمتطلبات الجهات الامنيه بالكشف
عن الجهات المسربه لبيانات المواطنين فضلا
عن موافقتها على تسميه قنوات رسميه للشركه
في البلاد الى اللقاء